hola a todos lo que quisiera hacer aquí
es hablar un poco de lo que es la
curvatura
curvatura muy bien y lo que he dibujado
aquí es el plano en quiché verdad y
tenemos una curva así que aquí tenemos
eje x g y esta curva digamos está
pintando en el espacio y quisiera que
imaginemos que este digamos alguna
especie de carretera en la cual estamos
manejando verdad y digamos que estamos
en cierto punto digamos que en este
punto de aquí y si imaginamos digamos
cómo tendríamos que manejar a lo largo
de esta carretera verdad donde hacia
donde tendríamos que mover nuestro
volante pues en realidad tendríamos que
moverlo hacia la derecha verdad y no
tanto porque hay una curva muy muy
ligera en este punto verdad no estamos
digamos no está muy curvado y ahora
imaginemos que nuestro volante se atasca
es decir no se va a mover y sin embargo
vamos a seguir dando la vuelta verdad
estamos atorados en esta situación que
es lo que va a ocurrir bueno esperemos
primero que estemos en un campo abierto
o algo así porque tu carro seguirá
trazando una trayectoria de un círculo
cierto así que sabemos que el volante no
puede hacer otra cosa distinta verdad
simplemente estamos girando
a cierta velocidad y eso es lo que va a
estar trazando un círculo gigante y esto
depende de donde nos encontremos verdad
si estuviéramos en un punto distinto
sobre la curva donde la curva digamos
estuviera rotando bruscamente verdad
digamos por ejemplo un poquito al inicio
verdad aquí al inicio tendríamos que
girar mucho más el volante hacia la
derecha verdad que y tendremos que girar
lo mucho más que en la otra parte de la
curva en donde estábamos en donde parece
relativamente digamos recto verdad y el
círculo que se dibuja como resultado es
mucho más pequeño verdad y esto resulta
ser una forma muy bonita para pensar en
una medida de que tanto se curva una
curva aunque suene chistoso y una forma
en la que podríamos hacer es pensar
bueno
cuál es el radio de este círculo el
círculo que trataríamos si nuestro
volante se atascara en un punto dado y
si seguimos este punto a lo largo de
distintas partes de la curva veremos
cuál es la diferentes círculos que en
nuestro carro podría trazar si se
atascara en puntos distintos
obtendríamos círculos que varían su
radio verdad y este radio de hecho tiene
un nombre muy especial y vamos a denotar
lo con la letra r mayúscula y esto se
llamará el radio de curvatura y puedes
ver qué tan que es una muy buena forma
de describir verdad que tanto estamos
girando hacia la derecha en este caso
verdad quizás hayas oído en las
especificaciones o las descripciones de
un carro que tiene cierto radio de giro
verdad digamos un carro que tiene un
radio de giro muy bueno es muy pequeño
verdad porque esto significa que si
giramos verdad hacia algún lado
simplemente hará dibujar ya un círculo
muy pequeño pero un carro con un radio
de giro muy malo pues entonces no va a
girar tanto verdad así que tras haríamos
un círculo mucho más grande y la
curvatura en sí misma no es esta esta r
verdad no es el radio de curvatura pero
lo que es es el recíproco de esto es
decir es uno sobre él y hay un film o un
símbolo especial para él y es una
especie de k
en realidad no estoy muy seguro cómo
hacerlo con manuscrita verdad así que
voy a distinguirlo con una cama yus cool
a ok y quizás lo voy a hacer un poquito
más curva dita por aquí en realidad esta
es la letra griega capa verdad y ésta es
la curvatura y lo que quiero que pienses
por un segundo es porque tomaríamos 1 /
r r es una descripción perfecta de que
tanto se curve a esta carretera así que
porque tendríamos que pensar en 1 / r en
lugar de erre misma y la razón
básicamente es que si queremos que la
curvatura sea una medida de qué tan
pronunciado es el giro en este caso
tendríamos que dar un número muy alto
así que si estamos en un punto en donde
estamos girando nuestro volante
muchísimo queremos que este resultado
sea un número grande verdad pero el
radio de curvatura en este caso tendría
que ser pequeño cuando estamos digamos
girando muchísimo así que si estamos en
un punto en donde básicamente es plano
es digamos el derecho verdad
tenemos una ligera curva que realizar
esto básicamente es digamos
una carretera recta así que queremos que
la curvatura en este caso sea un número
pequeño en este caso el radio de
curvatura es muy grande así que es muy
muy útil digamos tener uno sobre r como
la medida de que tanto gira una
carretera y en el próximo vídeo voy a
continuar digamos describiendo un
poquito más desde el punto de vista
matemático cómo es que vamos a capturar
este valor porque como parte de una
descripción vaga si digamos solo estamos
dibujando imágenes está muy bien decir
bueno imaginemos un círculo que está muy
cercano a nuestra curva que estamos
trazando y en realidad sería el
recorrido de nuestro auto si se atascara
el volante pero en términos matemáticos
vamos a describir esta curva paramétrica
mente verdad y será la salida de una
cierta función con valores vectoriales y
ahora lo que queremos saber es cómo
capturar esta idea del 1 entre r como
una idea de curvatura verdad en cierto
en alguna fórmula y eso es lo que vamos
a cubrir en los próximos vídeos